I gave happy deathday the first one a
good time if you're drunk but just to be
clear I came to enjoy happy deathday it
was an interesting movie with an
interesting premise and had fun with
that interesting premise whatever movie
like that comes a sequel that's
hopefully is good there we go
[Music]
happy deathday to you happy deathday to
you is I guess a valentine's movie we
get on Valentine's Day and once again
starts Jessica Roth as someone who broke
the cycle of reliving the same day over
and over and over again and getting
killed by a killer and every time she
got killed by a killer she had to relive
that same day over and over and over
again but something happens to word now
she has to relive that same day from
happy death day one over and over and
over again some things are different
which I really enjoyed that this movie
did that cuz I've always thought about
that it's essentially dealing with a
multiverse so this movie plays that up
and now let the mystery begin and that's
what this movie is I mean it's the
sequel to a slasher flick meets
Groundhog Day but it's not really a
slasher movie it doesn't feel like a
slasher movie it doesn't feel like
scream meets Groundhog Day it's it's own
thing now it's kind of going its own
direction it has slasher movie elements
sure but this sequel really goes its own
way to carve its own path as its own
movie its own franchise
when I walked out of the movie I was
like I the killer was kind of
underwhelming again cuz that was my
sentiment on the first movie with the
first killer but there's a whole segment
in this movie where it has nothing to do
with the killer at all she's like
alright well if I'm gonna die I'm gonna
kill myself so it's these fun ways of
killing herself cuz suicide I don't know
it made me laugh I'm sure people would
be like that how could you joke it's
where they're coming from they're
probably completely justified but for me
and I'm a twisted [ __ ] so made
me laugh that's gonna be a positive or
negative depending on what you want from
this movie where you're coming from the
killer felt like kind of a side note a
cliff note a cliff note in this sequel
to a movie that was a slasher movie I
felt like there's a killer in here
because there needs to be a killer in
here because the first movie had a
killer the whole thing with happy
deathday to you is that it delves deeper
into its lore or at science how did this
loop start how did it happen what caused
it to happen how can we fix it and it
didn't start with a killer so the killer
like I said cliff knows there are things
I'm just not invested in and don't buy
in this movie like the boyfriend element
she seems to really care about this dude
and I don't feel like she does care
about this dude you're dating in college
and it's easy to be like well you've
been dating for a day technically
speaking over her they've been dating
for more than a day for her they've been
dating for as long as she was in the
time loop which I think she said she
died
like 14 times something like that
they've been dating for two weeks still
probably don't buy it that's two weeks
what I just feel like this movie asks
you to be more invested in those two
then you really can and I said before
and I'll say it again Jessica Roth is
really good she's just really talented
she's charismatic in these happy
deathday movies she has good timing
comedic timing when she has to have a
scene that kind of hits the heartstrings
she turns on the waterworks and it works
cuz she works there is one scene where
there's some there's some feels dropped
but then I was getting the man tears I
was getting the mmm I'm not crying cry
if you don't feel something if you don't
kind of like well up and empathize in
this scene I don't know maybe you're an
[ __ ] that looks just maybe you're a
dick being an [ __ ] is your way of
navigating the world again it's an
[ __ ] ish world out there one has to
be an [ __ ] or a dick to navigate the
[ __ ]
yeah I was just feeling that same it was
good guys in the end happy deathday to
you it goes in a new direction it's not
as easily enjoyable as happy deathday
was happy deathday was simple killer
killing people kills us girl who relives
that same day until they unmask the
killer it solves the mystery the thing I
thought the movie on most is the fact
that it didn't know when to shut up so
you know those people that don't know
when to shut up as I didn't make a good
point and they keep talking and their
point starts to fall apart I actually do
that a lot that's why I use jump guys
point is if this movie had wrapped up
when this movie looked like it was going
to wrap it up it would have been better
so the whole time you're watching this
aftermath that's taking place after the
movie should have ended you're like I
don't care I don't care sweet alright
now can we end it when it ends it's just
really anticlimactic end credits come on
you're like oh I guess I guess that's
how it's gonna end
biggest flaw of the movie is that
regardless looking past that I enjoyed
happy death day to you I enjoyed happy
death day I'm looking forward to the
third one in fact if the third rat they
stick the landing to the third one and
they go in the direction it looks like
they're pointing towards going this
could be an enjoyable trilogy that
actually transcends the genre that
started it out it's pretty exciting
looking forward to that so I will say
happy death day to you was a good time
no alcohol required I so happy deathday
to you have you seen it why did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]